nobody knows what the self-driving cars
of the future will look like once you no
longer need a human in the front seat
operating a vehicle automakers can
rethink every aspect of car design since
the late 1960s however the federal
government has enforced detailed safety
standards governing the physical makeup
of the car virtually every part of the
car has had a standard written about it
there's about a hundred different
subjects that have been covered both in
advance notices and in actual standards
the Federal Rule books which have
expanded over the years have specifics
on everything from rearview mirror and
steering wheel placement to the shape of
the vehicle in the exact placement of
the seats since self-driving cars don't
need rearview mirrors steering wheels or
even seats necessarily what should the
federal government do with its roughly
nine hundred pages of regulations I will
make the contention that will rattle the
cage of some people in the auto
regulation business but basically the
entire vehicle code can be boiled down
to be safe and do not unfairly get in
the way of other people Brad Templeton
is an entrepreneur and software
architect who has worked as a consultant
with Google on its self-driving car
project he says most regulation will
become unnecessary and detrimental now
that motor vehicles are becoming
essentially computers on wheels
meaning software not just Hardware is
essential for safety it's necessary to
bring that wide true trusted means a
regulatory regulation to bear John
Simpson works at the california-based
non-profit consumer watchdog he says
that the transition to self-driving cars
doesn't mean we don't need stringent
safety standards you don't say the
algorithm will be written this way this
way this way and this way what you do is
you set a standard that says the vehicle
shall be able to do X under y
circumstance
[Music]
but the switch and emphasis from
hardware to software could change the
incentive structure in the car industry
in ways that make government oversight
less necessary one difference is that
when companies discover a safety flaw
they'll have every reason to fix the
problem immediately with today's cars
that hasn't always been the case take a
class example General Motors found a
flaw in the ignition switches and they
didn't do the right thing the American
public were failed by a corporate
culture that chose to conceal rather
than disclose replacing every ignition
switch it was very very expensive until
they were afraid of that cost but the
safety problems of the future will
primarily be bugs in software not
hardware so they'll be fixed by sending
ones and zeros over the internet without
the need to return hundreds of thousands
of vehicles to the manufacturer
replacing software is free so there's no
reason to hold back on fixing something
another difference is that when hardware
was all that mattered for safety
regulators could easily inspect a car
and determine if it met standards with
software scrutiny of this sort may be
impossible because the leading
self-driving car companies are
developing their platforms through a
process called machine learning machine
learning certainly doesn't mention with
traditional methods of regulation or of
software development frankly with this
method the vehicle recognizes patterns
in its environment and refines its own
system through driving experience but
machine learning which is a form of AI
is developed organically so humans have
limited understanding of how the system
actually works and that makes regulators
nervous
Templeton fears that our desire to
understand and control the underlying
system could lead governments to
prohibit the use of machine learning
technologies it turns out that they do a
better job but we don't know why we'll
be in this situation of deliberately
deploying the thing that's worse because
we feel a little more comfortable at we
understand it
should be John Simpson says extreme
caution is warranted because software in
cars isn't like software in other
contexts it's one thing to test Gmail in
beta mode the glitches and you lose your
messages and you say Oh hells bells I
lost my messages and software that when
it glitches actually might kill you and
I think that's an important distinction
to make that these need to be perfect
before we can allow them on the roads is
a mindset that has infected a lot of
urban planners and a lot of just the
general Pro regulation set mark Scribner
is a senior fellow at the free-market
think-tank the Competitive Enterprise
Institute he says that it's this mindset
that could cost lives on the highway
delaying self-driving car technology it
means we are going to see additional
deaths that we could avoid if we simply
would have allowed these vehicles on the
road that are not perfectly safe but
still safer than the cars we have today
the computerization of driving also has
an impact on how we build and maintain
highways some transportation planners
say that to prepare for self-driving
cars we need to construct smart
infrastructure that communicates
directly with vehicles Templeton says
that as driving becomes a software based
industry the physical highway should
mimic the Internet so the internet we
like to call it the stupid Network and
that's because a network is really
really simple when you're talking about
cars you talk about stupid roads and
smart cars you don't try and make the
infrastructure smart you make the
infrastructure as basic as possible and
you put the intelligence in the cars
where it's being built by lots of
competing companies and that's where you
get the piece of innovation that shook
the world that the internet if we need
to install all this new electronic
infrastructure on highways and we're
having problems filling potholes just
from a pure budgetary and management
perspective you're dreaming physical
infrastructure takes decades of planning
and implementation
Templeton says self-driving cars provide
an opportunity to make the roads quite a
bit dumber than they are today you take
what infrastructure you do need to
and you move it in the climate an
example it is the maps that Google uses
for their car to drive and they mapped
all the roads so they don't need anybody
to paint new lines on the road they use
that virtual infrastructure much cheaper
much more flexible much more ability to
change your mind about what you want
auto safety technology driven by the
private sector is it evolving much more
rapidly than the federal regulations and
some of them right now very clearly
stand in the way of consumers adopting
these safer technologies the more real
danger is that the benefits of this
technology will drive us to ignore the
necessary safety regulations right now
the impact the computers will have on
society is really really big here you
need a world where people are free to
come up with new innovations that
everyone else thinks they're crazy
[Music]